OK, let's. It's been a couple weeks, but I
do want to get to a new episode of Hatriot
Mail reminder. What is Hatriot Mail?
Why don't you take some hydroxyl chloroquine
for that Trump Derangement Syndrome hatred
mail written by patriots who hate David Pakman
because of America and because freedom.
OK. So, you know, sometimes if people hate
the show this much, maybe this just isn't
the show for you. Take a listen to this week's
Hatriot Mail and see if you come away with
the same same same feeling.
Cookman Pacman added again. The economy is
the people don't let this complacent cuk gaslight
you into destroying the only leverage you
have. Your votes, Pacman. The virus affect
too much your judgment. Your loud mouth will
cost you a very high price. Your Dimo rat
venom is mind blowing is all kweller like
you meaning moron stupid thinking only about
a demo. Rats are the best of the best polities
sins on earth. He worst and the most corrupt
channel there is on earth meaning park man.
I mean listen, I just don't think this is
though this is the show for you and that's
OK. And I, you know, I don't. I don't know
different people's viewing habits for programs.
I don't watch shows that infuriate me. I don't
watch shows that I believed to be corrupt.
I mean, as someone who covers bad media, you
know, I'm on some Digest's that let me know
this crazy thing happened on Fox. This crazy
thing happened on O n but I don't spend my
time watching this stuff. If it's not actually
things, it's not not relevant to my work or
something I want to consume. Just find something
else. That's my message. And by the way, terrific
opportunity. Speaking of the YouTube channel,
which they say is the most corrupt. We have
surpassed eight hundred and forty three thousand
YouTube subscribers. We are on the way to
eight hundred and fifty thousand, hopefully
then nine hundred thousand and hopefully then
the big milestone of one million YouTube subscribers.
Stunning. Incredible. When we started this
YouTube channel more than a decade ago. You
know, I think it took like a year close to
a year to get our first thousand subscribers.
We now regularly gain ten to twenty thousand
subscribers in one month. And I have only
you to thank so very much appreciated. You
can also take advantage of the coupon code
hatriot 40 to save 40 percent on a membership
of your choice at join Pacman dot com. That's
spelled hkt r i o t for zero. Sign up, join
Pacman dot com. Save 40 percent with the coupon
code.